what are event-driven architectures and
how can they enable
real-time user interactions pluggable
microservices
and extensible streaming and data
analytics
my name is whitney i'm on the cloud team
here at ibm
before i dig in on event driven
architecture specifically
i'd like to talk about system design
more generally
and specifically the reactive manifesto
the reactive manifesto is a set of
community-driven guidelines
that are intended to give a cohesive
approach to systems design
so at the core of the reactant manifesto
we have we want our system to be
message driven
and so specifically asynchronous
messaging
and then also we want our our system
design
to be scalable
and we want it to be resilient
so this implies distributed systems
or kubernetes so by scalable we mean
that we want the
hardware used to expand as the workload
expands and contract as the workload
contracts
and by resilient we mean we we don't
want any single point of failure
and if the system does fail we want it
to be able to tolerate
tolerate that elegantly so with this
foundation in place we should be able to
build
a system that is responsive responsive
is the value
on top of that we can expect a system
that is maintainable
so it means it's easy to change easy to
fix a bug or do an update
and we want one that is extensible
so we should be able to expand the
system easily
so now that we have the core of what we
want our systems designed to look like
now let's talk about let's level set
here and talk about like
what is an event
so an event is a statement of fact an
immutable statement of fact about
something that happened in the past
so let's give that some context we'll
talk about a retail application
so a retail application has a checkout
service
and that checkout service is going to
want to communicate
with an inventory service
a shipping service
and a contact service
so with the messaging model
if the inventory wants to know what the
checkout is doing
the checkout will send a message
directly to inventory to let the
inventory know a checkout happen
and another one directly to shipping and
directly to contact
so with messaging we have targeted
delivery
um not only that but inventory can maybe
send a message back to checkout it can
be a conversational
delivery conversational messaging
and then finally let's talk about where
that message lives
before it's sent it's it's lives on the
host service or on the producing service
when it's received it lives on the um
it lives on the host service until it's
received by the
consuming service or in the case of a
message broker it might sit on a machine
in between
but regardless the the data persistence
is
transient
now let's compare that to eventing so
if our checkout service is producing
events
it's producing an event every time a
checkout happens without any concern
to which service is consuming that and
so with that we have
a system that's highly scalable so we
have um
three services here interested in the
checkout
but even if we expand it to a hundred
services listening to check out
that wouldn't affect what the checkout
service is doing in any way
not only that when we have all the
checkouts in a row we come up with an
event log
and it can be replayable so we have a
stream history
and a history of everything that that
every checkout event that has happened
and then our data persistence depending
on how the cluster is set up
it can be set up to be immutable it can
be there forever
as long as you have the physical
hardware to back it up so we have um
instead of having transient data
persistent
so we have uh permanent or possibly
permanent
not immutable but permanent data
persistence
e and t um
so this is the foundation of our event
driven
architecture so we have a resilient a
reactive responsive
system design and then that message
driven element
is is event messaging specifically
so when we go into our proper event
design the first thing we're going to
consider
are our event producers so we might have
a web application
that produces events and we might have
a a mobile application
and let's say we also have an edge
device that's producing events so
uh internet of things device
and all of these are producing events
into our system
so
so this piece of the system here that
has all the events running through it
this is called the event backbone
so what does this system enable
well first of all we have our event logs
being produced by all the producing
applications
so the event logs can do a few things
first it can trigger an action so
if we have an internet of things device
let's say our internet of things device
is a robot vacuum cleaner and when we
turn on that robot vacuum cleaner
it spins up a pod on the infrastructure
and that pod is a function as a service
so
function as a service is a modular piece
of code often associated with an edge
device
that doesn't exist on a server on the
server until it is turned on
and that's when it is spun up so that's
called serverless function as a service
is sits on top of serverless
infrastructure
but the point is that event triggers an
action of the with the robot vacuum
cleaner
to spin up bounce all around the house
make everything
squeaky clean and then when the function
is finished running
it powers down and perhaps that'll cause
our function as a service to send
another event back into the system to
let it know
that the the function is complete
another cool thing about the event log
is it can be used
to help optimize and customize data
persistence
so if our web application is our
maybe it's our retail application that
we talked about before and it's
doing a stream of checkout events well
our inventory service
can be reading from that and it's
keeping
track of a local data store that's
keeping track of the inventory
so our inventory service will consume
from that data stream
from the web application it'll
modify the local data and then it'll
produce again
into the event backbone and so this new
stream is giving
the most current inventory to any other
application in the system that wants to
consume from it
and so while we're talking about data
another thing that happens
we can save all of the data that comes
through the system so all the raw data
or all of the transform data here at the
end once it goes through the system
we'll save it all
in a huge data lake
and this is what's going to power really
data-heavy applications
like ai for example and the data lake is
accessible from anywhere in the system
that any service that you let consume
from it
so another thing that our event-driven
architectures can enable
are a stream processing
so this is built on top of the apache
kafka streams api
so let's say that our mobile app is
producing
let's say it's a music streaming service
and
every time let's say up until your in
your whole life up until this point
you've been listening to only miley
cyrus and britney spears
but today you decide you know what i
want to see what jay-z is about
and you turn jay-z on well immediately
your streaming app is showing you kanye
west and lauren hill
and giving you ideas about what you
might want to listen to next
so that stream processing is a really
powerful
and what gives the gives real-time
calculations
like if it's a ride share app you um
that you know exactly how far away your
ride is
but it can also be used to implement
business rules and business
policies and it can be used for
real-time analytics
and then let's also talk about with our
system the communications layer
so specifically it's called pub sub
communication
for publish subscribe so we could have
any microservice a containerized
microservice
and just like we talked about before
with it being extensible
we can very easily plug it into we can
write a new microservice
and plug it into our system and
immediately have it
start consuming from any stream and
producing to a new stream or even
producing to a stream that already
exists
and none of the other applications need
to be concerned with it at
all so it's highly plugable not only
that
but because of the stream history we
talked about before
when you plug it into the system you
don't have to have it start consuming
from right this moment
it can be consuming from as long as from
the
beginning of your application if you've
been saving your stream history for that
long
so as long as that stream history
persists when you plug in a new
system it can consume from either the
old data or can be consumed from
the present moment so
with that we talked about the major
benefits of event driven architecture
that sit on top of the reactive
manifesto ideas for
system design with eventing at its core